>> Jesse: IT'S TIME FOR A VERY
SPECIAL EDITION OF MOM TEXTS.
WE HAVE A SPECIAL VISITOR IN
STUDIO FOR THIS INSTALLMENT, MY
MOM.
DR. WATTERS.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW, MY MOM IS A
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT AND SENDS ME
TEXTS CRITIQUING MY PERFORMANCE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: MY MOM IS A
CELEBRITY.
SHE IS IN THE GREEN ROOM AND
EVERYONE SAYS I HEARD SHE IS IN
THE GREEN ROOM.
CAN I MEET HER.
MANY ARE COMPLEMENTARY OF YOU,
DANA.
GREG, WHEN SHE SAYS HER NAME
CORRECTLY, SHE DOES THINK YOU'RE
INTERESTING.
>> Greg: PEOPLE ARE SURPRISED
YOU WERE BORN.
YOU CAME FROM HUMAN BEINGS.
>> Jesse: DOES THIS HUMANIZE
ME?
>> Greg: BARELY.
>> Jesse: HERE IS A SPECIAL
ONE.
MY MOM IS YOUR BIGGEST FAN.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> Greg: DO KNOW WHAT THAT
SAYS ABOUT YOU, DANA?
>> Jesse: YOU MIGHT REMEMBER
THIS FROM TWO WEEKS AGO.
THAT WAS SANTA SKYDIVING.
>> Dana: SO UPSETTING.
I THINK KIMBERLY WILL LIKE THIS.
DO YOU REALLY DO THAT?
>> Greg: OUR EYES ROLL WITH